we've all been reading over your study
and the ICC T's release and all of the
headlines on Fulks wagon but can you
just walk me through a timeline of when
you found out when you got to these
findings and when you release them to
the general public because most of us
only became aware of this on Friday yeah
actually I became oval you know aware of
the frenzy on Friday and we did this
testing in the spring of 2013 that that
testing concluded at the beginning of
summer you know at that time we had we
had measured the emissions in in the
real world on on board the vehicles
while they were doing their routes and
and we actually engaged our colleagues
at the California Air Resources Board
basically to verify that the vehicles
were behaving as as they should in other
words making sure we didn't pick a lemon
when we were renting a car to do the
testing their their data was
significantly different than our data
and and that that you know was confirmed
that confirmed to us that that we
weren't making poor measurements it was
simply you know there was no errors that
the vehicle was performing that way we
then took about a year to to go through
the data to write the report I mean if
it wasn't something that was
high-profile for us we work with our
colleagues at ICCT we got the data
presentation together we they published
the report on their website we presented
it in public forum one of our graduate
students mark Besh did on March 31st of
2014 and you know it was over a year and
a half basically before the announcement
came from the Air Resources Board in EPA
Kevin joining us from Princeton Kevin
what are we to make of all of this data
was it something that it seemed at least
to the naked eye that something had to
be going terribly wrong here whether
that was through negligence whether that
was done on purpose or whether it was
just an oversight right and I think Dan
could probably speak to this as well as
is we often see that the results in the
lab are different than what we see in
the real world even with mild
miles-per-gallon asked
and the testing done there there there's
often several different types of tests
that will yield different results and
one area we see that especially is as we
approach 2025 with corporate average
fuel economy standards you know it's
often difficult to find which is the
number that correlates to what we would
actually see if we were behind the wheel
driving the vehicle it's interesting
though Kevin that Dan and his team
started this study in 2013 put out the
findings in March of 2014 and it almost
seemed as if Martin vinter horn heard
about it for the first time last week
can you believe that senior executives
at Volkswagen didn't know about these
discrepancies and figure out why they
were happening until recently Kevin yeah
I mean that that would seem to me that
essentially and you see what the fallout
is in just these couple of days that
essentially somebody somewhere risked
the entire enterprise for it to cheat on
these tests for this this defeat device
I find that hard to believe that that's
that's one team or one person in a way
of making that decision on their own dan
I wonder about the fix obviously this
isn't the the the part of the the
problem that you guys worked on but NO x
emissions are the real problem here
apparently there are 10 to 40 times the
legal limit for at least one of these
vehicles is there an easy way to take
the NO x emissions out of the exhaust in
order to keep sort of the emissions
cleaner you know the the the two
Volkswagen vehicles had two different
technologies but you know we've done a
lot of work on those technologies
particularly in the heavy-duty market
even you know working with manufacturers
developing solutions it's really a
physics chemistry thermodynamics problem
and and you know you you're the energy
needed for activation of those systems
it largely comes from fuel so you know
there's a very complicated trade-off
there between drivability durability and
fuel economy dan I have to ask
smog tests are almost always done on
this
type of equipment aren't they actually
know that the equipment that we used is
is much more accurate much more I mean I
guess a lot of people get to get the
wrong impression that this was a small
little calculator sized device that you
said in that passenger seat but it's a
number of suitcases that takes about
eight hours to install on a vehicle
Kevin let me ask you we're hearing that
Matthias Mueller is going to be
nominated as CEO at least an interim
term to replace Martin Venter corn is it
possible that he didn't know anything
about this and how different our
Porsches diesel engines from Volkswagens
TDI's right so so porch wasn't one of
the one of the vehicles another 2.0
liter turbos so nothing from Porsches is
involved in in what will be the recall
you know so it's entirely possible if
Venter corn is saying he didn't know
mule over at Porsche you know was busy
enough running that business and running
it very effectively I might add that
it's entirely possible that he neither
had the opportunity or the wherewithal
to know those things dan dan as I
understand it
most modern diesel engines use urea
fluid to pull the NO x particles out of
the exhaust gases is that what was
missing in this instance and would that
it would that solve the problem actually
the the Passat was a was an SCR
technology so it did have the urea type
system the the Jetta has a lean NOx trap
and it does not use urea as a reductant
so the system was there the system was
just not active as much as it needed to
be Kevin I have to ask before we wrap
this we're talking about 11 million cars
what does this mean for the owners of
these cars what do they do yeah and I
think to mats earlier pointed and also
Dan's earlier point you're dealing with
clean diesel you're dealing with some
performance and you're dealing with
costs and it's it's it's almost
like pick two of those things so I think
more importantly the issue is when
Volkswagen gets through all these things
what is the strategy does diesel work
not only we see with the low numbers
here in the US but but even in countries
where that diesel penetration is much
higher you know is this a sustainable
engine technology going forward